coffee on a Tuesday and vlog 21 so I
have this thing about bookstores
whenever I walk by them it's sort of
like you know how in Vegas they they
pump scented air through the casinos to
make the gamblers feel good well
whenever I walk by a bookstore I get the
smell of books in my face and I just
have to go in and I could spend all day
in there the reason I usually leave is
because I start to get lightheaded and
realized that I've missed lunch and it's
coming up on dinner and people are
expecting me and I have to do this thing
and write that email and and move on
with my day and maybe it's not smart for
one to analyze the charm of bookstores
but well I've already sort of started it
and anyway I read this article in The
Times yesterday and it's got me thinking
about it see the article said that
Barnes and Noble has predicted that in
the coming year it will lose more money
than even Wall Street had predicted it
would and this after the bankruptcy and
disillusion of borders its main
competitor is the specter of ebooks with
Amazon and it's Kindle as a dominant
force threatens to diminish this this
last chain of booksellers and if they do
you might be left buying your your
bestsellers at places like Target or
Walmart and it's ironic because it was
Barnes & Noble which drove so many
independent booksellers to bankruptcy
sort of like what Tom Hanks does to meg
Ryan and you've got mail with his
in-park multi-level homogenized the
world Mochaccino land now Mochaccino
land might be the last best hope for
print books and publishers like penguin
and Random House and Simon & Schuster
who used that that front of the store
display table to premiere new talent to
push the next big thing a table which is
especially important for new writers
like me now to fight off the Kindle
Barnes & Noble has the Nook and it has
boosted some revenue to the company
though it's hard to fight off both
Amazon and Apple at the same time David
had enough trouble fighting just the one
Goliath William Lynch the new CEO of
Barnes & Noble has done everything he
possibly can to stay relevant and head
of the
but his company is worth this much while
Amazon's is worth this much and I guess
we'll see how it plays out but I paused
to wonder if there is something lost by
the digitizing of books in the possible
end of bookstores it's safe to say that
someone reading a book on their Kindle
or Nook is having an experience which is
negligibly different from reading a
paper book the story is still there the
words arranged as they are still
produced the same magic the same music
of mental images that only pros can make
that won't be lost I guess what I fear
is not the death of stories but rather
the end of the physical space which
those stories take up walking through
the stacks and shelves of the bookstore
all our past and present knowledge looms
cast shadows on you maybe you get more
accurate a sense with all that papered
space of the distance we've come as a
thinking race it's like a real living
interactive timeline it's not the same
with a selection of e-books on your iPad
is no space they're just scrolling you
can't see each and every page tight
against the next and you can't see the
overstock or the display table or the
books people have taken out of their
shells but decided not to buy so there's
a million variables in the bookstore
variables stretched over space and time
and it's true that sometimes the book
like a magic ring can find you and maybe
there's an alchemy in that which would
be a shame to lose or maybe I'm just
being sentimental
fräulein burner DML can attest here
easy-cheesy
Oh